So this week, lots of people looked at the election results and thought, yeah, this is the country that I thought it was. And for some people, that was a really hopeful thing, and others, kind of the opposite. And let's start with the winners. I'm joined in the studio right now by Zoe Chace.
本周，许多人看着选举结果心想，这就是我心目中的国家。对一些人来说，这充满希望；而对另一些人来说，情况恰恰相反。让我们先从获胜者说起，现在演播室里和我在一起的是佐伊·查斯。
Hello.
你好。
Hey there, Zoe. So election night, you and I were in Michigan together, and you got to go to the Republican victory party.
你好，佐伊。选举之夜，你和我一起在密歇根州，你还去了共和党的胜选派对。
I did.
是的，我去过。
Let's bring in the sound.
让我们听听那里的声音。
Waiting for anything substantive--
等待任何实质性的进展——
There it is.
就在那儿。
As I walk in, the polls were closing. The results were starting to come in. I have to say, I walked in kind of prepared for the last war, like the last election.
我走进去的时候，投票站正在关闭。结果开始陆续出来。我必须说，我走进去的时候还带着上一场战争的心态，就像上次选举那样。
Explain what you mean.
解释一下你的意思。
Well, I know a lot of these Republicans in Michigan. I know they've been mobilizing, for years, an army of poll watchers and poll challengers and lawyers to challenge the results of a fraudulent election. So I come in expecting super tight results, and a long fight, and tension, and anxiety, and suspicion.
嗯，我认识密歇根州的很多共和党人。我知道他们多年来一直在动员，组织了一支由投票观察员、投票质疑员和律师组成的军队，试图挑战所谓的“欺诈选举”结果。所以我来的时候预期会是极其胶着的局势，会有漫长的争斗、紧张、焦虑和猜疑。
[CROWD CHEERING]
[人群欢呼]
And?
然后呢？
That is not what I found.
我看到的并不是这些。
[CROWD CHEERING]
[人群欢呼]
What are people cheering for?
大家在欢呼什么？
We're up in Pennsylvania. We just tied in Michigan.
我们在宾夕法尼亚州领先。我们在密歇根州刚刚追平了。
[INDISTINCT CHATTER]
[嘈杂的谈话声]
Look at that.
看那个。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I'm so happy.
我太高兴了。
[INDISTINCT CHATTER]
[嘈杂的谈话声]
My heart's going to pop out of my chest.
我的心都要跳出来了。
Really?
真的吗？
Feels like it.
感觉是这样。
It's Eric Castiglia, longtime Republican activist. He runs a PAC called Brighter Michigan. He believes the last election was rife with fraud-- not this one. In fact, there was never a moment, once the count started, where anyone in this room wasn't believing the results.
他是埃里克·卡斯蒂利亚，一位长期的共和党活动人士。他经营着一个名为“更光明密歇根”的政治行动委员会。他认为上次选举充满了欺诈，但这次不是。事实上，当计票开始后，房间里没有任何一刻是怀疑选举结果的。
Well, yeah, because it was all breaking their way.
嗯，是的，因为局势完全朝着他们有利的方向发展。
I know, but also, these are the people on the ground who ran the ground game in Michigan, and they were feeling really good about what they did.
我知道，但这些人也是密歇根州一线选战的组织者，他们对自己所做的工作感到非常满意。
All right, Eric. What's going to happen?
好了，埃里克。接下来会发生什么？
I think he's going to win, baby. He's going to win. I'm so happy. I am so happy, Zoe. You have no idea.
我认为他会赢的，宝贝。他会赢。我太高兴了。我真的太高兴了，佐伊。你根本无法想象。
So it was obvious to them they were going to win way before it was obvious to you.
所以在你意识到他们会赢之前，他们早就心知肚明了。
Yes, very much. Like, when I was talking to Amber Harris-- we first met last year. She's a Republican activist.
是的，非常清楚。比如，当我与安布尔·哈里斯交谈时——我们是去年第一次见面。她也是一名共和党活动人士。
I didn't honestly expect the night to go this way in general.
老实说，我根本没想到昨晚会是这个走向。
Oh. I did.
哦，我预料到了。
Really?
真的吗？
I did, yeah. We worked really hard for this. And I'm happy. I'm very happy. We worked really, really hard. We knocked a lot of doors. We went into territories that we never would have, whether it was Detroit-- because we had nothing to lose. As a party, we have nothing to lose besides talking to people. And I think that this is a very-- this is what came when you just talk to people. [LAUGHS] Like--
是的，预料到了。我们为此付出了巨大的努力。我很高兴。我非常高兴。我们真的工作得非常辛苦。我们挨家挨户敲门。我们去了那些从未涉足的地区，比如底特律——因为我们没什么可失去的。作为一个政党，除了与民众交谈，我们一无所有。我认为这就是当你真正与民众交谈时所产生的结果。[笑] 就像——
She's right that more people came out. The Republican vote in Michigan was unprecedented. Trump got more votes than he did last time he ran in Detroit, in the surrounding suburbs, in almost every county in the state of Michigan.
她说得对，确实有更多人出来了。共和党在密歇根州的投票率是空前的。特朗普在底特律、周边郊区，以及密歇根州几乎每一个县的得票数都比他上次参选时要多。
OK. So then, at some point in the night, Trump wins.
好的。那么，在那天晚上的某个时候，特朗普赢了。
Yes, much earlier than I was expecting.
是的，比我预期的要早得多。
Let's hear some sound of that.
让我们听听当时的场景。
Yes!
耶！
[CROWD CHEERING]
[人群欢呼]
Trump! Trump! Trump! Trump!
特朗普！特朗普！特朗普！特朗普！
Thank you.
谢谢。
And I see a guy breaking down crying at the front of the room. He's the regional director for Macomb County.
我看到一个男人在房间前面泪流满面。他是马科姆县的地区主管。
What was it that you think did it?
你认为是什么促成了这一切？
What did it?
什么促成的？
Yeah.
对。
I think people realized that we're better off with President Trump, that he provided a great, great way of living for us, that he provided a way for us to provide for our families. And I think people miss that. I think people truly miss that. I think they just yearn to go back to where we were. And I think people believed in him.
我认为人们意识到在特朗普总统的领导下我们会过得更好，他为我们提供了非常棒的生活方式，他让我们有能力养活家人。我觉得人们怀念那种生活。我真的觉得人们怀念那种生活。我觉得他们只是渴望回到过去的日子。而且我认为人们相信他。
And that's true-- some people. And some did not.
那确实是真的——对一些人来说。但也有一些人并不这么想。
Yeah, I believe I've heard that.
是的，我相信我听过这种声音。
Somebody I had checked with a couple of days after the election was Danny Hodges. He's a Washington, DC, policeman who was one of the officers who defended the Capitol building back on January 6. He was beaten. Somebody tried to gouge out his eye. He was trapped by the crowd at one point, and a man took his nightstick and hit his head. In the wake of that, he's testified in Congress and at the trials of a number of people who attacked the Capitol, including one last week.
选举后几天，我联系过丹尼·霍奇斯。他是一位华盛顿特区的警察，是1月6日保卫国会大厦的警官之一。他当时遭到了殴打。有人试图抠出他的眼睛。他一度被人群困住，一名男子抢走了他的警棍并击打他的头部。在那之后，他在国会作证，并在针对袭击国会的多名参与者的审判中出庭，包括上周的一场审判。
And when I talked to him, he said something that I heard from a bunch of Democrats. It's like, it wasn't just disappointment he was feeling, but a whole feeling that I can only describe as "whoa."
当我与他交谈时，他说出了一些我从许多民主党人那里听到的想法。那不仅是失望，而是一种我只能用“哇”来形容的复杂情绪。
Like many people, I'm sad and confused. I'm still wrapping my head around how so many people could vote for Trump after everything we know about him, everything he's done. I don't understand it. I don't get it.
和许多人一样，我感到悲伤和困惑。我仍然无法理解，在了解了他的一切作为之后，为什么还有这么多人投票给特朗普。我不理解。我不明白。
Since January 6, you've spoken so much about what happened to you at the Capitol-- over four years. When you started on that path, what did you hope it would accomplish?
自1月6日以来，你多次谈到你在国会大厦经历的事情——已经过去四年了。当你开始这条路时，你希望达成什么目标？
[LAUGHS] The opposite of this. I hoped that I would communicate to the people that what happened was real, that Trump sent an armed mob to stop the peaceful transfer of power. I wanted people to understand this, and in the hope that they would respect the rule of law and that they would have respect for the Constitution and choose their leaders with that in mind in the future. But I guess that wasn't at the top of everyone's priorities.
[笑] 恰恰相反的结果。我希望向人们传达那天发生的一切是真实的，特朗普派遣了武装暴徒来阻止权力的和平移交。我希望人们能理解这一点，并希望他们尊重法治，尊重宪法，在未来以此为前提选择领导人。但我想这并不是每个人的首要任务。
And what's it like to look at the possibility that President Trump might do what he said he would do and let all these people free from January 6?
如果特朗普总统真的履行诺言，赦免所有1月6日事件的参与者，你对此有何看法？
It's hard to process. I don't know. I don't know what to say about that except that I have no influence over that and I've just got to roll with it, however it happens.
这很难消化。我不知道。除了说我对此毫无影响力，必须顺其自然之外，我不知道该说什么。
Today, after the billions of dollars spent and the countless hours of literally hundreds of thousands around the country who knocked themselves out for this election canvassing, donating, poll watching, doing everything they knew how to do, now, here we are, still a divided country, staring at each other across an abyss, but with a clear winner.
今天，在投入了数十亿美元，全国数十万人为这场选举不遗余力地进行拉票、捐款、观察投票、做尽了他们能做的一切之后，我们依然是一个分裂的国家，隔着深渊彼此凝视，但有了一个明确的赢家。
We thought what we could do here on our show is spend some time with a few of the people who felt very strongly about the outcome of this race, who have a special, personal investment in it, looking ahead with them to what's next. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
我们觉得可以在节目里花点时间采访一些对这场竞选结果深感关切、有着特殊个人投入的人，展望他们的未来。来自芝加哥WBEZ广播电台，这里是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
It's This American Life, Act One-- our act names today, by the way, are quotes from the president-elect-- "The Largest Deportation Operation in American History." So mass deportations are coming. Donald Trump promised it. People waved mass deportation signs at his rallies. It was the first item on the Republican Party's platform this year. And at the Republican National Convention, Tom Homan, the guy who ran ICE under Trump, the Immigration and Customs Enforcement, had a message for undocumented immigrants-- you'd better start packing now.
这里是《美国生活》，第一幕——顺便说一下，我们今天的节目名称取自当选总统的语录——“美国历史上最大的驱逐行动”。所以，大规模驱逐行动即将到来。唐纳德·特朗普承诺过。在他的竞选集会上，人们挥舞着大规模驱逐的标语。这是今年共和党纲领的第一项内容。在共和党全国代表大会上，特朗普任内的ICE（移民及海关执法局）局长汤姆·霍曼向非法移民发出了一条信息——你们最好现在就开始打包。
President Trump has claimed he's going to be able to deport between 15 and 20 million people. His Vice President, JD Vance, said the number is lower, that they could do one million people per year. But Donald Trump and his team have never spelled out exactly how they would do this. Our producer, Nadia Reiman, wondered about that, and looked into what mass deportation could actually look like if and when it comes to pass.
特朗普总统声称他将能够驱逐1500万到2000万人。他的副手万斯说数字会少一些，他们一年可以驱逐100万人。但唐纳德·特朗普及其团队从未明确说明他们将如何实施这一计划。我们的制作人纳迪亚·雷曼对此感到好奇，并深入调查了如果大规模驱逐行动真正发生时会是什么样子。
I was kind of unfazed at first when I heard about Trump's mass deportation campaign promise. I've been covering immigration for years. There are so many undocumented people here that we can't even keep count. The closest estimate is 13.3 million. So it's a big job to round up all of these people and to send them back to countries that may not take them. It's expensive. It's time-consuming. It's a crazy task.
刚听到特朗普的大规模驱逐竞选承诺时，我最初并没有太在意。我报道移民问题多年了。这里的非法移民人数多到我们甚至无法统计。最接近的估计是1330万。所以，把这些人全部找出来并遣返回那些可能根本不接收他们的国家，是一项巨大的工程。这昂贵、耗时，简直是疯狂的举动。
But then I was talking to a source inside the Department of Homeland Security. And I said something like, I mean, I know there's no way Trump can do this mass deportation thing. And they stopped me. They were like, oh, sure, it can happen. They said it so casually, like it was a given. So I wanted to talk to someone who could break down how. Like, exactly how could you do something so massive?
但后来我与国土安全部的一位消息人士交谈。我说，我的意思是，我知道特朗普根本不可能实施这种大规模驱逐。他们打断了我。他们说，噢，当然，这完全可能发生。他们说得那么随意，就像这是一件理所当然的事。所以我想要找一个能拆解具体实施方法的人。比如，究竟该如何完成如此庞大的任务？
I tried talking to Tom Homan. He's rumored to be the next ICE director under Trump but has denied there's a written plan for mass deportations. And he ghosted me. Jason Houser, however, was eager to talk. He was the chief of staff for ICE under Biden for a couple years, has been working for DHS on and off since 9/11, mostly in enforcement.
我尝试联系汤姆·霍曼。有传言称他是特朗普政府下任ICE局长的候选人，但他否认有关于大规模驱逐的书面计划。他没理我。然而，杰森·豪泽非常乐意交谈。他是拜登政府期间ICE的幕僚长，自9/11事件以来，他一直在国土安全部断断续续地工作，主要负责执法。
He's passionate about all of this, in his wonky, government guy way. I talked to him for 3.5 hours, asked him basically to play pretend, game some stuff out with me. What would happen in the first 100 days? If he was in charge of ICE, what could he do to carry out this mass deportation mandate?
他以那种官僚主义的、精明的风格，对这一切充满热情。我与他交谈了3.5个小时，基本上请求他和我进行模拟推演。如果头100天会发生什么？如果他是ICE的负责人，他能做些什么来执行这项大规模驱逐指令？
Jason thinks that, first of all, the new Trump administration will immediately start to prep for this-- like, the day after the election, this week. They would start talking to law enforcement in different cities and getting them to agree to cooperate, hit the ground running in January. ICE would talk to home countries to get them to agree to take people back. And after those two things align, Jason says, ICE could decide to deport someone and they'd be out of the country within 24 hours.
杰森认为，首先，特朗普新政府会立即为此做准备——比如选举后的第二天，即本周。他们会开始与不同城市的执法部门沟通，争取合作，并在1月份开始实施。ICE会与来源国沟通，要求他们同意接收遣返人员。当这两件事协调一致后，杰森说，ICE可以决定驱逐某人，并在24小时内将其送出境。
I think the first 90 days is going to be hell. You're going to see the buses. You're going to see the migrants in your home-- not just blue cities, red cities-- Miami, Houston, Charlotte-- like, red states-- Kansas City, St. Louis.
我认为前90天将是地狱。你会看到大巴车。你会看到移民就在你家附近——不仅是在民主党控制的蓝市，还有红色城市——迈阿密、休斯顿、夏洛特——甚至是红州——堪萨斯城、圣路易斯。
You're going to see kids not in your schools. You're going to know where they're at because they're waiting in a detention cell and they have cell phones. You're going to see it in social media. You're going to see businesses not be able to open up because their workers didn't show up. You're going to see businesses being raided. And it's going to become more intimate.
你会发现孩子们不再出现在学校里。你会知道他们在哪，因为他们正被关在拘留所里，手里拿着手机。你会在社交媒体上看到这一切。你会看到企业因为员工没来上班而无法开业。你会看到企业被突袭。这一切将变得更加切身。
This isn't going to be about separating a family at the border, that somebody doesn't know that family member. You're talking about separations and movements in your communities where you're going to know the guy-- Bill, Juan, Luis. You're going to know the individuals.
这不再只是边境上的家庭分离，那是你不认识的某个家庭。这说的是发生在你社区里的分离和人员迁徙，你会认识那个家伙——比尔、胡安、路易斯。你会认识这些个体。
One of the things ICE would have to work around is which nationalities to deport first-- you know, if you wanted to make the most impact. A lot of countries don't take their own people back. Venezuela, for example, hardly accepts any immigrants back. Brazil only accepts two to four flights of immigrants a month.
ICE需要克服的问题之一是优先驱逐哪些国籍的人——你知道，如果你想产生最大的影响的话。许多国家不接收自己的国民。例如，委内瑞拉几乎不接收任何被驱逐的移民。巴西每月只接受两到四架移民遣返航班。
So who are the first people who would be deported, like, in the first hundred days?
那么，谁是前100天里最先被驱逐的人？
Haitians and Guatemalans.
海地人和危地马拉人。
Haitians and Guatemalans?
海地人和危地马拉人？
These countries take back the most flights. So I have an ability to remove-- at volume-- individuals. A lot of them have entered through pathways that we've developed, where we've gained biometric, we've gained vetting, and we've--
这些国家接收的航班最多。所以我能够大规模地遣返个人。其中很多人是通过我们开发的途径进来的，我们掌握了生物识别信息，进行了审查，而且我们——
Meaning we know where they are.
意味着我们知道他们在哪里。
Yeah, we know where they are. We know where they are. They're working, non-criminal. We go out, we find them. We're going to find nationalities that are easily removable. And we're probably going to do it at volume with single adults first, because removing families is more complex. You've got to hold them, detain them, put them in hotels. It's very staff-intensive. So I'm going to target down on single adults and nationalities where I know the country will take them back very, very quickly.
是的，我们知道他们在哪里。我们知道他们在哪里。他们正在工作，是非刑事犯罪人员。我们出去找到他们。我们可能会优先寻找容易遣返国籍的人。我们可能会先针对单身成年人进行大规模行动，因为遣返家庭更复杂。你必须关押他们、拘留他们，把他们安置在旅馆里。这非常耗费人力。所以我将把重点放在单身成年人身上，以及那些我确定该国会迅速接收他们的国籍人群。
OK. So Haitians and Guatemalans and then--
好的。所以是海地人和危地马拉人，然后——
There's other populations too, but--
还有其他群体，但——
Who's next after those two?
在这两个群体之后是谁？
Hondurans, right? We talk about Guatemalans, Hondurans, Nicaraguans, the countries where you see daily-- just in the news and the reporting by DHS and Homeland Security-- where are the most removal flights occurring? Those are the countries that accept those flights.
洪都拉斯人，对吧？我们谈论危地马拉人、洪都拉斯人、尼加拉瓜人，这些国家每天都在新闻和国土安全部的报告中被提及——哪里发生的遣返航班最多？那些就是接收航班的国家。
But if I'm in this scenario where I'm the head of ICE for Trump, all the rules of engagement and policies are out the window. Why not load up a few planeloads of Cuban nationals and send them to the Bahamas and just send them to a third party? Why not just-- I could go find a country that says they'll accept three or four planeloads of Cuban nationals, and I'll send them to a third-party country.
但如果我身处这个情境中，我是特朗普治下的ICE负责人，所有的交战规则和政策都被抛到了窗外。为什么不装满几飞机古巴人，把他们送到巴哈马，送给第三方？为什么不——我可以找一个愿意接收三四飞机古巴人的国家，然后把他们送到第三方国家。
Jason says ICE can focus on getting people in eight major cities with airport hubs-- Philadelphia, DC, Chicago, Houston, Miami, Denver, New York, and LA. Those have access to quick ICE flights to people's home countries. Jason thinks ICE can get people out before they can get to a judge or a lawyer.
杰森说ICE可以专注于拥有机场枢纽的八个主要城市——费城、华盛顿特区、芝加哥、休斯顿、迈阿密、丹佛、纽约和洛杉矶。这些地方可以快速安排ICE航班前往遣返对象的祖国。杰森认为ICE可以在这些人接触到法官或律师之前就把他们送走。
And one way to catch a lot of people quickly, especially the ones who snuck in and ICE has no info on, is to bring back worksite enforcement, a.k.a., large-scale raids. The Biden administration stopped doing those.
而快速抓捕大量人群——尤其是那些潜入且ICE没有任何记录的人——的一个方法是恢复工作场所执法，即大规模突袭。拜登政府已经停止了这样做。
Do you think there would be raids, then, in the first 100 days?
那你认为前100天内会发生突袭吗？
I think there would be raids within the first three weeks.
我认为在最初的三周内就会有突袭。
Really?
真的吗？
Yeah. Those are not hard to turn on. Like, to operationalize those, those aren't hard.
是的。启动这些并不难。要将其投入运作，并不难。
Where? Where would they do them?
在哪里？他们会在哪里进行？
You would go back to where there's big ICE and Customs and Border Protection resources to do enforcement. And you would do them in communities that would show the most cruelty. So there's nothing that would stop a Trump administration from going into the workplace, going into our hospitality sector, going into restaurants or businesses, and arresting individuals at scale.
你会回到那些拥有大型ICE和海关与边境保护局资源来进行执法的地方。而且你会在那些最能体现残酷性的社区里进行。因此，没有任何东西能阻止特朗普政府进入工作场所、进入我们的服务业、进入餐馆或企业，并进行大规模的个人逮捕。
Can you walk through what that would look like? What do you think that would look like?
你能演示一下那是什么样子的吗？你认为会是什么场景？
Well, I think it would be very easy to focus on industries that have large numbers and high numbers of migrants working within them. What would stop them from going into a meat processing plant in Virginia? Say there's a couple hundred migrants. There's 80 on shift that day. You go in, you know there's one individual there that has a final order of removal, maybe has a nonviolent criminal background.
嗯，我认为专注于雇佣了大量移民的行业是非常容易的。有什么能阻止他们进入弗吉尼亚州的一家肉类加工厂呢？假设有几百名移民，那天正好有80人在上班。你进去，你知道那里有一个有最终驱逐令的人，可能还有非暴力的犯罪背景。
You go in, you do the raid, you line all the workers up, and you start checking status of each and every one of them, right? Or maybe you just arrest them all, bring them into detention, and then do the checks to see who is removable. There's nothing that could stop ICE, at that point, from just bringing people into custody, detaining them, and then figuring out who is removable at that time.
你进去，进行突袭，让所有工人排好队，开始核查每一个人的身份，对吧？或者你可能直接把他们全部逮捕，带进拘留所，然后再做核查看看谁是可以被驱逐的。在那一点上，没有什么能阻止ICE直接将人拘留、关押，然后再弄清楚谁是可以驱逐的。
Tom Homan has not denied this, by the way. He's said publicly something like this would be necessary. Homan also said he would do national security threats first-- but then raids, sure. Jason says the raids under a 2.0 Trump administration could be more militarized, with SWAT-style teams. That's not how they've been done in the past. He also told me he thinks nothing would stop ICE from going into hospitals or schools or churches. Normally, ICE doesn't do that. But this is just a policy, not a law.
顺便说一句，汤姆·霍曼并没有否认这一点。他在公开场合说过，这样做是必要的。霍曼还说，他会先针对国家安全威胁——但随后是突袭，当然。杰森说，特朗普2.0政府下的突袭可能会更加军事化，配有特警式团队。过去的情况并非如此。他还告诉我，他认为没有什么能阻止ICE进入医院、学校或教堂。通常情况下，ICE不会那样做。但这只是政策，不是法律。
So after doing these raids and trying to get people out quickly, ICE would be left with lots of immigrants that they have to hold until they can get them deported. I wanted to know, where would you hold all these people?
所以在进行了这些突袭并试图快速遣送人员之后，ICE将会剩下许多必须关押直到能够驱逐的移民。我想知道，你会把这些人关在哪里？
Would you build tent camps to hold people?
你会建造帐篷营地来关押人吗？
If I'm not looking out for the care of the law enforcement officers that are overseeing it or the migrants, yes, you could. When we did all the evacs and ICE had a very big support in the evacuation out of Afghanistan, we brought on soft-sided facilities at Fort Dix, New Jersey, and other places around the country. But again--
如果我不考虑执法人员或移民的照顾问题，是的，可以。当我们进行所有撤离行动时，ICE在阿富汗撤离行动中得到了非常大的支持，我们在新泽西州迪克斯堡和全国其他地方启用了软质设施。但再次强调——
Soft-sided facilities? Is that euphemism for tents?
软质设施？这是帐篷的委婉说法吗？
Well, yes. They're big, sort of like fair-- like, carnival tents. They're very thick plastic, and they're soft. Yeah. But what I'm saying is, let's say we put a thousand--
嗯，是的。它们很大，有点像集市——像嘉年华帐篷。它们是很厚的塑料，是软的。是的。但我说的是，假设我们要安置一千人——
You're like, they're weatherproof. They're weatherproof. But they're tents.
你就像在说，它们是防风雨的。它们是防风雨的。但它们就是帐篷。
Well, they're not just, like, Coleman tents that you would get to go camping. But what I'm saying is-- but the problem here is, those Afghanis were coming to safety. Now, you're saying, I'm going to bring on a soft-side tent to hold people so I can remove them in, like, 90 days.
嗯，它们不像那种你去露营时买的科尔曼帐篷。但我说的是——问题在于，那些阿富汗人是来寻求安全的。现在你却说，我要启用软质帐篷来关押人，这样我可以在90天内把他们移走。
The idea that they're just going to, like-- OK, I'm going to live in this deplorable conditions and not cause unrest-- that's where it gets very dangerous.
他们会安分守己地生活在这种凄惨的环境中，不引起动乱——那种想法才最危险。
Dangerous because Jason thinks there would be fights, riots. People would be hurt, possibly even die, he thinks. And just so I'm clear here, yes, he means immigrants, but also officers. Jason's very concerned about the safety of the ICE officers.
危险是因为杰森认为会发生斗殴、暴乱。他认为人们会受伤，甚至可能死亡。我想澄清一下，是的，他说的是移民，但还有警员。杰森非常关心ICE警员的安全。
Where else can you hold people you want to deport? Can you house migrants in jails?
你还可以把想要驱逐的人关在什么地方？你可以把移民安置在监狱里吗？
Yes.
可以。
Could you lower jailing standards to put more people in a cell?
你可以降低监狱标准，把更多人塞进一个牢房吗？
Yes. Well, yes, absolutely.
可以。嗯，是的，绝对可以。
Right.
对。
But yes.
但是的。
Like, I'm saying, could you-- our standard before was three people per cell, and now, we're saying it's six.
我是说，你可以——我们之前的标准是每个牢房三个人，现在我们说它是六个。
That is policy. It is not law. So yes, of course you could.
那是政策。不是法律。所以是的，当然可以。
OK. Could you turn places quickly into detention centers or camps? Like, can you change the standards to make it faster?
好的。你可以快速地把地方变成拘留中心或营地吗？比如，你可以改变标准来加快速度吗？
Yes. I could have-- between FEMA and ICE and DHS, we could turn on 25 old warehouses, old department stores in a week.
可以。我可以在一周内动用联邦紧急事务管理局、ICE和国土安全部，启用25个旧仓库、旧百货商店。
Wow, in a week.
哇，一周之内。
Well--
嗯——
So definitely doable in the first 100 days.
所以在前100天内绝对可以做到。
--it would just be a cement building with some mats. And then I make sure we have porta-potties, some food. I have a couple docs there in case somebody gets really sick. And then I bring in a couple hundred security guards. I could do that in a week.
——它只是一个水泥建筑，铺上一些垫子。然后我确保有移动厕所，一些食物。放几个医生在场，以防有人病得很重。然后再调来几百名保安。我一周内就能搞定。
At the end of the 100 days, how many people do you think will be gone?
在100天结束时，你认为会有多少人离开？
Let's just say this. Let's say all rules are out the-- and I can remove people that aren't removable. Like, I'm going to send them to third-party countries. ICE has 48,000 people in its custody now. ICE has 14 ICE planes that are hardened planes. They hold 135-- 135 souls. I need more of those. But while I'm sending those 48,000, I'm probably going to go out and bring another 50,000 to 100,000 into custody. So if you're talking 30 to 60 days, you could remove 150,000 to 200,000 people.
我们这样说吧。假设所有的规则都——我可以移走那些不可驱逐的人。比如，我把他们送到第三方国家。ICE目前有48,000人在其监管下。ICE有14架强化飞机。它们可容纳135人——135个灵魂。我需要更多这样的飞机。但在我遣送那48,000人的同时，我可能会出去再带5万到10万人进入拘留所。所以如果你谈论的是30到60天，你可以驱逐15万到20万人。
So 200,000 people in the first 60 days?
所以在前60天内有20万人？
Yeah.
是的。
So in the first 100, that puts you at what, how many?
所以在前100天内，那加起来是多少人？
If all rules are gone and I can remove them anywhere, you could do a million.
如果所有的规则都没了，我可以把他们移到任何地方，你可以驱逐一百万。
A million people. Of course, Jason's predicting here, assuming there will be no major roadblocks. But the Brennan Center did this thing where they stress tested with experts and government people whether mass deportations could be done, gamed this all out. In their simulations, funding was a big obstacle right away, so their deportation numbers weren't as large as Jason's.
一百万人。当然，杰森在这里的预测是假设没有任何重大障碍。但是布伦南中心做过一项研究，他们与专家和政府人员进行了压力测试，看看大规模驱逐是否可行。在他们的模拟中，资金是一个很大的即时障碍，所以他们的驱逐数字没有杰森的那么大。
But that was also assuming that the House wouldn't go Republican, which is looking like it will be as I record this. That would make Jason's math of a million people more possible. And when a million people disappear from the country, it's more than just bodies gone. There's ripple effects.
但那也是假设众议院不会被共和党控制，而正如我录音时显示的那样，这看起来将会发生。这会使杰森的一百万人计算变得更可能。当一百万人从国家中消失时，这不仅仅是肉体消失了。这会产生连锁反应。
One, we'll see massive inflation continue in this country, because we just pulled a million people out of our workforce-- GDP, businesses, small business especially. And then we'll see thousands of people losing their jobs and small businesses closing, et cetera.
第一，我们将看到这个国家的通货膨胀大幅持续，因为我们刚刚从我们的劳动力——GDP、企业，尤其是小企业——中抽走了一百万人。然后我们将看到成千上万的人失去工作，小企业倒闭，等等。
Two, law enforcement activity-- federal specifically, and in cities and states where state and local law enforcement is supporting this mass deportation program-- will halt. Halt. Going out and arresting the rapist and murderer in your county will stop while your sheriff is over playing grabass with Homan and these individuals and trying to do some big mass deportation scheme and throwing Grandma back to Cuba. So law enforcement will be chilled.
第二，执法活动——联邦层面，以及州和地方执法部门正在支持这一大规模驱逐计划的城市和州——将会陷入停滞。停滞。当你的治安官正忙着和霍曼以及这些人鬼混，试图搞什么大规模驱逐计划，并把老奶奶扔回古巴时，出去抓捕你县里的强奸犯和杀人犯的工作将会停止。所以执法活动会变得迟缓。
Three, migrants will go deeper into the shadows. They will do the steps they need to stay in our country, because it's so much better than going back and risking death in another that they will hide even more into the shadows.
第三，移民将更深入地潜入阴影中。他们会采取他们需要采取的步骤留在我们国家，因为这比回去并冒着在另一个国家死亡的风险要好得多，所以他们会藏得更深。
And so those that are left behind, it's like they become ghosts. They might stop showing up to work. Maybe they'll move. You'll notice them missing-- at your local grocery store, your bar, your daycare. And at the same time, your screens will be broadcasting the deportations on TV, on social media, shouting the images of a million who are actually gone. Jason thinks this will be strategic.
于是那些被留下的人，就像成了鬼魂。他们可能会不再出现工作。也许他们会搬走。你会注意到他们失踪了——在你当地的杂货店、酒吧、托儿所。同时，你的屏幕将会在电视上、社交媒体上广播驱逐过程，大肆宣扬那一百万已经真正离开的人的图像。杰森认为这会是策略性的。
I think there's going to be lined-up planes, engines-running imagery of mass removals. I think they're going to grab people and intentionally break our policy, like, break the law and throw some people back to their home country. And then when the courts push back, they can be like, see, the courts made us stop. Because then they can go, hey, look at these bureaucratic pencil necks getting in our way. This is the deep state. This is the deep state.
我认为会有排队的飞机、引擎运转的图像，显示大规模驱逐。我认为他们会抓人并故意打破我们的政策，比如违法把一些人扔回他们的祖国。然后当法院进行反击时，他们可以像说，你看，是法院让我们停下的。因为他们可以去说，嘿，看看这些官僚主义的笨蛋在阻碍我们。这就是深层政府。这就是深层政府。
I guess my thing is, to what end, though?
我大概想问的是，为了什么目的呢？
Winning the midterms.
赢得中期选举。
You think it's all political? You don't think there's any ideological thing that he wants out of it?
你认为这一切都是政治？你不认为他有任何想从中得到的意识形态吗？
Sure, I think he's ill-equipped. But there's 8 million just on the immigration docket now. How many people have status here and are first-generation migrants, or from migrant families? I mean, we're talking-- this would affect, like, 50 million to 100 million people, these sort of actions. The idea that there isn't political consequences to that, even for Donald Trump-- I think the pendulum would swing back.
当然，我认为他能力不足。但单是移民案件档案里就有800万人。有多少人在这里拥有合法身份，或者是第一代移民，还是来自移民家庭？我的意思是，我们说的是——这种行动将影响约5000万到1亿人。认为这对唐纳德·特朗普也没有政治后果的想法——我认为钟摆会摆回来。
I'm not so sure. I think it's way harder for the pendulum to swing back. If you look at the Democrats' immigration platform, what you see is the border bill that Biden tried to pass. That bill is the most restrictive immigration bill we've seen in years. It's a child born out of the Trump administration but also parented by the Democrats, making a harsh agenda seem way more middle of the road.
我不那么确定。我认为钟摆要摆回来要难得多。如果你看看民主党的移民纲领，你会看到拜登试图通过的边境法案。该法案是多年来我们见过的最严格的移民法案。它是特朗普政府的产物，但也是由民主党抚养长大的，使得强硬议程看起来更像中庸之道。
Think piece after think piece uses this failed bill as an example of how far to the right we've moved on immigration, how much enforcement and severity have taken over, how much the idea of a nation of immigrants is dusty and Pollyanna-ish. This fall, a Brookings poll said that about a third of Americans agree with Trump's quote, that undocumented immigrants are poisoning the blood of the country-- "poisoning the blood."
一篇又一篇评论文章用这个失败的法案作为例子，说明我们在移民问题上向右移动了多少，执法和严厉程度占据了多少主导地位，说明移民国家的理念是多么陈旧和幼稚。今年秋天，布鲁金斯学会的一项民意调查显示，约三分之一的美国人同意特朗普的引语，即非法移民正在毒害这个国家的血液——“毒害血液”。
This phrase chills me. It's not about legality or order. It's visceral. It's guttural repulsion. It is a violent feeling about a massive group of people. And when the President is the one that leads it, it's not just a feeling anymore. It becomes an action.
这句话让我不寒而栗。这与合法性或秩序无关。它是发自肺腑的。它是喉咙深处的排斥感。这是对一大群人的暴力感。当总统是那个引领它的人时，它就不再仅仅是一种感觉了。它变成了一种行动。
Nadia Reiman. She's an editor on our show.
纳迪亚·雷曼。她是我们节目的编辑。
Two days after the election, two of our producers, Emmanuel Dzotsi and Lilly Sullivan, went to this church near her office in New York City where, on certain days, there are migrants and asylum seekers getting free legal advice and meals. And they met this guy, Roberto, who told him that he arrived in the US five months ago from Ecuador. And he's been having trouble sleeping ever since Election Day. Lilly now joins me in the studio. Hey, Lilly.
选举两天后，我们的两位制作人伊曼纽尔·佐齐和莉莉·沙利文去了纽约市她办公室附近的一座教堂，在那里，在某些日子，有移民和寻求庇护者获得免费法律咨询和餐食。他们遇见了那个叫罗伯托的家伙，他告诉他们他五个月前从厄瓜多尔来到美国。自选举日以来，他一直难以入睡。莉莉现在加入了我们的演播室。嘿，莉莉。
Hey, Ira.
嘿，艾拉。
So you spoke with him.
所以你和他说过了。
Yeah. He's been staying in a shelter nearby. And he says he can already picture it, what the ICE raids there would be like.
是的。他一直住在附近的一个收容所里。他说他已经能想象出那里的ICE突袭会是什么样子了。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语交谈]
He says, let me describe it like a movie. He pictures a group of 100, 200 men arriving, who'd lock up the building and go floor to floor.
他说，让我把它描述得像一部电影。他想象着一群100、200名男人到达，他们会封锁大楼并逐层搜查。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语交谈]
No one would be able to get out.
没有人能够出去。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语交谈]
And they'd load them up into buses or cars or whatever ICE uses and deport them. Like, that's what you hear about. So that's what he imagines about how it might go.
他们会把他们装进大巴车或汽车，或者ICE用的任何东西，然后驱逐他们。就像，这就是你听到的传闻。所以这就是他想象中可能会发生的情况。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语交谈]
On the streets, he feels a little freer, he told me, because if someone tried to grab him, he could just run. He'd have that option.
在街上，他觉得自由一点，他告诉我，因为如果有人试图抓住他，他可以跑。他会有那个选择。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语交谈]
But in the shelter, he's between four walls. There's nowhere to run.
但在收容所里，他在四堵墙之间。无处可逃。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语交谈]
I asked him, where do you feel safe? He told me, here, in the church where I talked to him. There's no other place where he can feel calm. Because he tells me, ICE can't come into the church.
我问他，你觉得在哪里安全？他告诉我，在这里，在我和他谈话的教堂里。没有别的地方能让他感到平静。因为他告诉我，ICE不能进入教堂。
Though, of course, in President Trump's next term, that might not be true.
当然，在特朗普总统的下一个任期，那可能就不成立了。
Yeah. We have this idea of sanctuary spaces. But anytime ICE decides they want to go into churches or hospitals or schools, they can do that.
是的。我们有这种避难所空间的想法。但任何时候ICE决定他们想要进入教堂、医院或学校，他们都可以那样做。
Act Two, "Nobody Loves Our Latino Community and Our Puerto Rican Community More than I Do." So Donald Trump won record numbers of Latino voters this year, more than any Republican candidate since they started tracking that demographic in exit polls back in the 1970s. So how'd it happen? Ike Sriskandarajah spent the day with a guy who's been gunning for this for years.
第二幕，“没有人比我更爱我们的拉丁裔社区和波多黎各社区”。所以唐纳德·特朗普今年赢得了创纪录数量的拉丁裔选民，比自1970年代出口民调开始跟踪该人口群体以来的任何共和党候选人都多。这是怎么发生的？艾克·斯里斯坎达拉贾花了一天时间与一个多年来一直致力于此的人在一起。
I first met Sam Negron a few weeks ago outside a Trump rally in Allentown, Pennsylvania. He's waiting in the VIP line because, one, he's a constable. That's like an elected sheriff. And, two, he volunteers a lot for the campaign-- knocks on doors, does phone calls, is something called a Trump Force Captain, and works with Latinos for Trump.
几周前，我在宾夕法尼亚州阿伦敦的一次特朗普集会外第一次见到山姆·内格龙。他在VIP队伍里排队，因为，第一，他是治安官。那就像民选的警长。而且，第二，他为竞选活动做了很多志愿服务——挨家挨户敲门、打电话，是所谓的“特朗普力量队长”，并与“拉丁裔支持特朗普”组织合作。
It's nice to meet you. Sam.
很高兴见到你，山姆。
Ike. Sam?
艾克。山姆？
Yes, sir.
是的，先生。
Pleasure.
荣幸。
I never had no cool nicknames like Pookie or Tito.
我从来没有像普基或铁托那样酷的绰号。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
It's just Sam.
就是山姆。
Sam's a proud Puerto Rican-- big guy, classic cop haircut. And he gets personal fast. When I tell him Ike is my nickname, he says, we tend to do that in America-- shorten things. Then he calls me his brother.
山姆是一位自豪的波多黎各人——个子大，典型的警察发型。而且他很快就变得私人化了。当我告诉他艾克是我的绰号时，他说，我们在美国倾向于那样做——缩短名字。然后他叫我兄弟。
Go ahead, brother. You should be recording this.
来吧，兄弟。你应该录下这个。
We're surrounded by long lines of Trump supporters who start chanting because they see a protest coming down the street. It's maybe a couple dozen people waving Puerto Rican flags. They're with a Latinx social justice group here to protest the "island of garbage" comment that a comedian recently made at a Trump rally.
我们被长长的特朗普支持者队伍包围，他们看到街对面有抗议活动就开始高呼。那是大约几十个人挥舞着波多黎各旗帜。他们是一个拉丁裔社会正义团体，来到这里抗议一位喜剧演员最近在特朗普集会上发表的“垃圾岛”言论。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语交谈]
Puerto Rico!
波多黎各！
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语交谈]
Puerto Rico!
波多黎各！
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语交谈]
A couple of Sam's friends from Latinos for Trump rush over. They're going to cross the street to go confront the anti-Trump protesters. And they ask Sam to join.
几个来自“拉丁裔支持特朗普”的山姆的朋友冲了过去。他们要过马路去与反特朗普抗议者对峙。他们要求山姆加入。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语交谈]
He tells them, I don't like to fight. Let them speak.
他告诉他们，我不喜欢打架。让他们说吧。
See, but what I don't like-- to do the combating thing.
看，但我所不喜欢的是——搞对抗。
Go back to your own fucking country!
滚回你该死的国家去！
I didn't hear what they were saying, but--
我没听见他们在说什么，但是——
Another Trump supporter nearby, a white lady in a red shirt, is shouting over us at this whole scrum of Spanish speakers, not really differentiating between the Trump supporters and the Trump protesters. She says, they don't even speak English. Go back to your own fucking country.
附近另一位穿红衬衫的白人妇女，对着这群说西班牙语的人大喊大叫，并没有真正区分特朗普支持者和特朗普抗议者。她说，他们甚至不说英语。滚回你该死的国家去。
Yeah. See, that's not cool.
是的。看，那不酷。
What do you do with that?
你对此怎么处理？
Things like that, it's not cool. But you know what? I'm Puerto Rican, papi. I grew up in the South Bronx in the '70s. I've gotten racism from everybody. Because you see my color, right? I'm very light-skinned. Growing up in the South Bronx wasn't easy in the '70s.
那样的事情，不酷。但你知道吗？我是波多黎各人，爸爸。我在70年代的布朗克斯南部长大。我从每个人那里都受到过种族歧视。因为你看到了我的肤色，对吧？我肤色很浅。在70年代的布朗克斯南部长大并不容易。
It doesn't get under your skin, is what you're saying?
你的意思是，这不会让你感到困扰？
No. So I tend to ignore that. You know what I found out working on this campaign? That is not the majority.
不。所以我倾向于忽略它。你知道我在这次竞选中发现了什么吗？那不是大多数。
For most of his life, Sam supported Democrats. But in 2016, he broke with the party, protest voted for Jill Stein. He got into Trump from videos shared by a Latino Trump supporter. Then, just in the past two years, he lost both his son and his son-in-law. They overdosed on fentanyl. He says it's a big problem in Allentown. And he felt like the Democrats and Biden weren't helping. It made him want Trump back even more.
山姆一生中大部分时间都支持民主党。但在2016年，他与该党分道扬镳，抗议投票给吉尔·斯坦。他通过一位拉丁裔特朗普支持者分享的视频开始接触特朗普。然后，就在过去两年里，他失去了儿子和女婿。他们因芬太尼过量而死。他说这是阿伦敦的一个大问题。他觉得民主党和拜登没有提供帮助。这让他更想让特朗普回来。
So he started evangelizing, trying to convert people. He's got lit and signs-- Boricuas for Trump, Dominicans for Trump. He's got these little scratch-offs for Trump. It was lonely at first in this Democratic city, but slowly, it started to feel like it was working. He'd been stepping it up for months. And then "island of garbage" dropped on him.
所以他开始传教，试图转化人们。他有传单和标语——“波多黎各人支持特朗普”、“多米尼加人支持特朗普”。他有这些特朗普的小刮刮乐。起初在这个民主党城市很孤独，但慢慢地，它开始感觉奏效了。他几个月来一直在加强攻势。然后“垃圾岛”的言论落在了他身上。
I hear my wife going, look what just came out. Look what they said. She was furious.
我听到我妻子说，看刚刚发生了什么。看他们说了什么。她很愤怒。
It was hurtful because that's where they're from, but also frustrating, because he's been out here in these streets, trying to pull his people one by one towards Trump.
这很伤人，因为那是他们来自的地方，但也令人沮丧，因为他一直在这里，在大街上，试图把他的同胞一个接一个地拉向特朗普。
I was double upset because I'm like, one, that's an ugly joke. Two, there goes all the work I've done for the last four or five years.
我加倍沮丧，因为我像，第一，那是个丑陋的笑话。第二，我过去四五年所做的所有工作都白费了。
Did you think those comments might just cost him the whole election?
你认为那些言论可能会让他输掉整个选举吗？
Totally, brother. I said, oh, my god, there goes everything we've done-- [LAUGHS] right out the window.
完全是，兄弟。我说，天哪，我们所做的一切都随着——[笑] 窗外去了。
So how to reconcile all this, being a proud Puerto Rican and a die-hard Trump supporter? For Sam, it took 20 minutes of googling.
所以如何调和所有这一切，作为一个自豪的波多黎各人和坚定的特朗普支持者？对山姆来说，这花了20分钟的谷歌搜索。
Anytime something controversial comes out of that campaign, there's something else behind it. You know what I found out?
每当那个竞选活动传出有争议的事情时，背后总有别的东西。你知道我发现了什么吗？
Here's how he explains that there was actually a deeper message hidden inside that joke.
这就是他解释那个笑话里实际上隐藏着更深层含义的方式。
Puerto Rico's drowning in trash. They haven't been able to get rid of their trash for the last four years. There's 29 dump sites all over Puerto Rico that are mountains of trash because they can't burn because of carbon emissions. And who did that? Back four years ago, wasn't as bad-- it went way overboard four years ago. So that's what I believe was the reference that was being made to.
波多黎各被垃圾淹没了。过去四年他们没能处理掉垃圾。波多黎各各地有29个垃圾倾倒场，全是垃圾山，因为他们不能因为碳排放而焚烧。是谁干的？四年前，没那么糟——四年前太过分了。所以我认为那是所指的参考。
20 minutes of research got Sam from livid about a potentially campaign-derailing bad joke to outrage at an environmental disaster he lays at the feet of the Biden administration. If that sounds like opportunistic reasoning, Sam gets that.
20分钟的研究让山姆从对一个潜在的竞选脱轨坏笑话的愤怒，变成了对一个环境灾难的义愤，他把这个灾难归咎于拜登政府。如果这听起来像是机会主义的推理，山姆明白这一点。
Did you need to find a reason for it?
你需要为它找个理由吗？
Heck yeah, I needed a reason for it. Like I said, I--
该死的，我需要一个理由。就像我说的，我——
So he went on a mission, the weekend before the election, to do damage control, tell people what he learned and get them to vote for Trump. He also wanted to give people a chance to talk through the ways they felt let down by Democrats. I tagged along because I wanted to know if people would buy it. And part of what I heard helped me understand why Trump took a historic share of the Latino vote.
所以他带着使命，在选举前的周末，进行了损害控制，告诉人们他学到了什么，并让他们投票给特朗普。他还想给人们一个机会，谈谈他们觉得被民主党辜负的方式。我跟随而去，因为我想知道人们是否会买账。而我听到的一部分帮助我理解了为什么特朗普获得了拉丁裔投票的历史份额。
And the way Sam's doing it, he's not following an orderly list of registered R or independent voters. He's going off-book. Here, in the Supremo Grocery Store parking lot in the heart of a Latino neighborhood, it's a busy Sunday. There's a lot of shoppers, steady flow of people on the sidewalk. It's a target-rich environment.
而山姆的做法，他不遵循一份注册共和党人或独立选民的有序名单。他是不按常理出牌。在这里，在拉丁裔社区中心的Supremo杂货店停车场，这是一个忙碌的星期天。有很多购物者，人行道上人流不断。这是一个目标丰富的环境。
Hi.
嗨。
[INAUDIBLE]
[听不清]
Good, mami, how you doing? You voting this year?
好吗，妈妈，你好吗？你今年投票吗？
[INAUDIBLE]
[听不清]
Come talk to me. Come--
过来跟我说。过来——
Sam spots a Puerto Rican woman he knows pulling into the parking lot.
山姆发现了一位他认识的正在开进停车场的波多黎各妇女。
You're parking? Go park. Come talk to me.
你在停车吗？去停车。过来跟我说。
Damned if I do, damned if I don't.
做了也得受罪，不做也得受罪。
Right, that's the problem.
对，那就是问题所在。
Damned if I do, damned if I don't, she yells from the car. This is Melissa. Sam and her clearly go back. But he says he doesn't know how she's going to vote.
做了也得受罪，不做也得受罪，她从车里喊道。这是梅丽莎。山姆和她显然很熟。但他说他不知道她会怎么投。
Don't do it. I've got a bad filter right now.
别做。我现在的过滤器很差。
That's all right. No.
没关系。不。
So [INAUDIBLE].
所以[听不清]。
How you feeling right now?
你现在感觉怎么样？
Upset.
心烦。
Uh-huh. But what are you upset about?
嗯哼。但你在为什么心烦？
What I'm upset is that I'm a taxpayer and I don't get shit. And you've got other people that come into our country, and they give them everything. But then you want to sit here and want to downgrade Spanish people. Make that shit make sense.
我心烦的是我是一个纳税人，我什么都没得到。你还有其他人来到我们国家，他们给了他们一切。但然后你想要坐在这里想要贬低西班牙裔。让那该死的逻辑说得通。
She's upset about Democrats giving support to new arrivals in the country instead of focusing on the people already here, people like herself. She also doesn't tolerate insults against Spanish-speaking people. So she doesn't like her options.
她对民主党支持新来者而不是关注已经在那里的人，关注像她这样的人感到心烦。她也容忍不了对说西班牙语的人的侮辱。所以她不喜欢她的选择。
Can we talk about Sunday, a week ago at the Garden?
我们可以谈谈上周天在花园的事吗？
The joke the comedian made about the island of garbage?
喜剧演员做的关于那个垃圾岛的笑话？
Mm-hmm.
嗯哼。
OK. How you feel about that?
好的。你觉得怎么样？
How you feel about it?
你觉得怎么样？
I was livid. I told this man--
我很愤怒。我告诉这个人——
Sam walks her through how he figured out the island of garbage comment is actually a sneaky PSA about landfill mismanagement. Melissa listens.
山姆引导她了解他是如何弄清楚垃圾岛的评论实际上是一个关于垃圾填埋管理不善的偷偷摸摸的公益广告。梅丽莎听着。
--four years ago. So that's what I believe was the reference that was being made to.
——四年前。所以我认为那是所指的参考。
How does that sit with you?
你觉得那怎么样？
I could show you. [INAUDIBLE].
我可以给你看。[听不清]。
That's facts. That's what you call facts. But again, everybody's so much into their social media, their social media only portrays one side of each story. You understand what I mean? So if you sit here and you analyze both sides of the stories-- like I said earlier in my car, damned if you do, damned if you don't. You understand what I mean? Because here, we got-- our felons couldn't never vote, right?
那是事实。这就是你所谓的真相。但同样，每个人都在他们的社交媒体上太深了，他们的社交媒体只展示了每个故事的一面。你明白我的意思吗？所以如果你坐在这里分析故事的两面——就像我在车里早些时候说的那样，不做也得受罪。你明白我的意思吗？因为在这里，我们有——我们的重罪犯永远不能投票，对吧？
How come illegal immigrants are able to vote now?
非法移民现在怎么能投票？
Exactly. Why?
完全正确。为什么？
Where does that put us?
那把我们置于何地？
Not true-- illegal immigrants can't vote.
不是真的——非法移民不能投票。
Where does that put us that been here all our lives? And that's a right. That's a citizenship right. That's not a human right. That's a citizenship right. You want to vote, go back to your country and vote-- not in a bad way, not meaning that you should go back to your country. But you know what? Get in line and wait like everybody else.
那把我们这些一辈子都在这里的人置于何地？那是一种权利。那是一种公民权利。那不是人权。那是一种公民权利。你想投票，回到你的国家去投票——不是坏的那种方式，不是说你应该回到你的国家。但你知道吗？排队等待像其他人一样。
Because there's been a lot of illegal immigrants in this country that have been here for years still waiting for their papers, thousands on lawyers--
因为在这个国家有很多非法移民已经在这里多年仍然在等待他们的文件，数千人雇佣律师——
--and can't even vote--
——甚至不能投票——
--[INAUDIBLE].
——[听不清]。
--and can't even vote. And pay their taxes-- and pay their taxes.
——甚至不能投票。并且纳税——并且纳税。
Yes.
是的。
The backdrop here is that Sam and Melissa are Puerto Rican. They're already citizens who can vote if they live on the mainland. They don't have to wait in any sort of line.
这里的背景是山姆和梅丽莎是波多黎各人。他们已经是如果住在美国本土就可以投票的公民。他们不需要排任何队。
--given up everything.
——放弃了一切。
Eight years ago, Melissa supported Hillary. She says Bill Clinton was a hell of a president. Now, she likes Trump, in spite of the comment.
八年前，梅丽莎支持希拉里。她说比尔·克林顿是一位了不起的总统。现在，她喜欢特朗普，尽管有那个评论。
Was I in the same boat a couple of years ago? Absolutely not. I wanted him out. I didn't want to keep dealing with that. You understand what I mean? Great businessman.
几年前我也在同一条船上吗？绝对不是。我想要他下台。我不想继续处理那个。你明白我的意思吗？伟大的商人。
Right, which [INAUDIBLE].
对，[听不清]。
Great businessman. What fucked him up was his filter and how he speaks to people--
伟大的商人。搞砸他的是他的过滤器和他如何对人说话——
Coming from somebody--
来自某人——
--you understand what I mean?
——你明白我的意思吗？
--who ain't got no hair--
——谁没有头发——
On my tongue.
在他的舌头上。
--on her tongue.
——在她的舌头上。
But let's be realistic here. The way he spoke in front of our kids-- you're the president. But he put it out there. And again, me being a person who doesn't have no filter myself, I can understand that. But there's a time and a place for everything. But at this point, I'd rather go here than go there, because I don't want to get more digged in a hole than what I am now and get the same shit that I got for the past four years.
但让我们在这里现实一点。他在我们孩子面前说话的方式——你是总统。但他把它表达出来了。而且同样，作为一个我自己也没有过滤器的人，我可以理解。但凡事有时有地。但在这一点上，我宁愿去这里也不愿去那里，因为我不想比现在更陷入泥潭，得到我过去四年得到的同样的东西。
Melissa ends the conversation by telling Sam she'll vote for Trump. Sam approaches another Puerto Rican guy, a soft-spoken young man named Marcus, and asks him how he felt about the insult.
梅丽莎通过告诉山姆她会投票给特朗普结束了谈话。山姆接近另一个波多黎各人，一个叫马库斯的说话轻声细语的年轻人，并问他觉得侮辱有什么感觉。
I think he said it was a-- do you guys know there's an island of garbage floating in the ocean? I think it's called Puerto Rico. How'd that make you feel, papi?
我想他说那是一个——你们知道海洋里漂浮着一个垃圾岛吗？我想它叫波多黎各。那让你觉得怎样，爸爸？
I mean, as a Puerto Rican, it made me feel like shit.
我的意思是，作为一个波多黎各人，这让我觉得像狗屎。
Right. Trust me. I was livid, bro. I was mad, bro. But what that did for me-- I went online and started looking up, is there a problem in Puerto Rico with any type of garbage or anything? You know what I found out?
对。相信我。我很愤怒，兄弟。我很生气，兄弟。但那对我做了什么——我上网开始查找，波多黎各有什么垃圾之类的问题吗？你知道我发现了什么吗？
Sam takes Marcus through his spiel, from livid to landfill-- seems like it's sinking in. They talk more about the price of eggs, which is smart, given Marcus just left the grocery store. And after Sam finishes, I asked Marcus how he feels about Sam's explanation about the island of garbage.
山姆带着马库斯经历了他的说辞，从愤怒到垃圾填埋——看起来它正在沉入。他们谈论更多关于鸡蛋的价格，这是明智的，考虑到马库斯刚离开杂货店。在山姆说完后，我问马库斯他对山姆关于垃圾岛的解释感觉如何。
When I first heard it, I was appalled that our leadership could speak so disgustingly about us that way. And even as he was just mentioning it right now, it's just-- it's disgusting.
当我第一次听到它时，我很震惊我们的领导层竟然能那样恶心地谈论我们。即使他刚才提到它时，它只是——它很恶心。
He's still pissed about the comment, but he was planning to vote for Trump anyway. And Sam's explanation?
他仍然对这个评论感到生气，但他还是打算投票给特朗普。而山姆的解释？
It just made it feel all the much better that there's a valuable explanation as to his comment, because that's who I'm leaning towards, is Trump. So it feels very good to know that.
这只是让它感觉好多了，因为对他的评论有一个有价值的解释，因为这就是我倾向于，是特朗普。所以知道这一点感觉非常好。
The next guy, a Spanish speaker carrying a large bag of dog food, didn't even need to hear Sam's explanation. He just wants to share his critique of the Democrats' failures. Here's Jose.
下一个人，一个拿着一大袋狗粮的说西班牙语的人，甚至不需要听山姆的解释。他只是想分享他对民主党失败的批评。这是何塞。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语交谈]
Jose is saying that neither party wants to fix immigration. Obama had two years to do something when the Democrats controlled the House and the Senate, and they didn't.
何塞说没有一个党想修复移民问题。奥巴马有两年时间可以在民主党控制众议院和参议院时做些什么，但他们没有。
He's informed.
他很了解情况。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语交谈]
And is he going to vote for Trump?
他要投票给特朗普吗？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语交谈]
He's voting for Trump too. The garbage joke, people can get past that. But what they can't get past is how Democrats have been letting them down in a bunch of different ways. Sam is pleased.
他也投票给特朗普。垃圾笑话，人们可以越过它。但他们无法越过的是民主党如何在许多不同方面让他们失望。山姆很高兴。
I'm feeling a lot more positive than I was a couple of days ago. And I'm glad that especially the Puerto Ricans that we did talk to were still going to support him regardless. We all feel the same way. We're mad about the comment. It upset us. But it's policy over feelings, brother.
我感觉比几天前积极多了。我很高兴特别是我们交谈过的波多黎各人仍然会支持他。我们都有同样的感觉。我们对评论很生气。它惹恼了我们。但它是政策重于感情，兄弟。
You cleaned up today.
你今天清理了。
I feel a lot better, brother, because I was worried. I thought I was going to come out here and have to put on the boxing gloves and duke it out with people. And it hasn't been that at all.
我感觉好多了，兄弟，因为我担心。我以为我会在这里不得不戴上拳击手套和人们打斗。但这根本不是那样的。
I don't think you've met--
我不认为你见过——
Anti-Trumper.
反特朗普者。
--a Harris supporter.
——哈里斯的支持者。
Nope. And they're out here.
不。而且他们在这里。
Sam did talk to one Harris supporter, a younger Dominican man.
山姆确实和一个哈里斯支持者谈过，一个年轻的多米尼加人。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语交谈]
The man says he can't vote. He'd like to become a citizen, vote someday. Again, this is where a traditional canvasser would pivot. That's not Sam.
这个人说他不能投票。他想成为公民，有一天投票。再次，这是传统拉票者会转向的地方。那不是山姆。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语交谈]
If he could vote, he'd vote for Kamala. Hey, there's one. Now, this close to the election, campaigns are a numbers game of maximizing turnout of eligible, like-minded voters. This guy is neither.
如果他能投票，他会投票给卡马拉。嘿，有一个。现在，离选举这么近，竞选活动是最大化合格、志同道合选民投票率的数字游戏。这个人两者都不是。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语交谈]
The guy says he wants a change. Sam sees an opening-- a change from what?
这个人说他想要改变。山姆看到了一个机会——改变什么？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语交谈]
Sam makes his pitch for Trump and asks him to think about it.
山姆为特朗普做了他的推销，并请他考虑一下。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语交谈]
[LAUGHS] I left him thinking. He's almost flipped. My whole mission is to wake people up in my community. To me, it's not about the vote. To me, it's about our people. And that's the way I look at it.
[笑] 我留他在思考。他几乎被翻转了。我的整个使命是唤醒我们社区的人们。对我来说，这与投票无关。对我来说，这与我们的人民有关。而这就是我看它的方式。
To Sam, it's the long game. This isn't just about the election that just happened. It's about the next one and the next one and the one after that.
对山姆来说，这是长期的博弈。这不仅仅是关于刚刚发生的选举。这是关于下一次和下一次以及下一次之后的那一次。
Ike Sriskandarajah is a producer on our show.
艾克·斯里斯坎达拉贾是我们节目的制作人。
Coming up, all those people on Trump's enemies list who he's been calling for retribution against, are they packing their bags? We check in with a couple. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
即将到来，特朗普名单上的那些他一直在呼吁报复的敌人，他们正在打包行李吗？我们与几个人核实。那是一分钟后，当我们的节目继续时，来自芝加哥公共广播电台。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program-- "This is the Cake We Baked." Today, we have stories of people who have some special, personal investment in the outcome of this week's election, and we look at what's coming for them. We have arrived at Act Three of our show.
它是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目——“这是我们烤的蛋糕”。今天，我们有对本周选举结果有特殊、个人投资的人的故事，我们看看对他们来说会发生什么。我们已经到达了我们节目的第三幕。
Act Three, "Sometimes Revenge Can Be Justified." So in the final weeks of his campaign, Donald Trump only stepped up his threats of retribution against his political enemies, including saying he'd use the military to go after the enemy within. Two people who've been keeping an eye on these sorts of comments are Alexander and Rachel Vindman. Alex is the army officer who officially reported what seemed like an improper phone call between President Trump and the president of Ukraine, which led to Trump's first impeachment trial. Rachel is his wife.
第三幕，“有时候报复是可以证明的”。所以在竞选的最后几周，唐纳德·特朗普只是加剧了他对政治敌人的报复威胁，包括说他会使用军队去对付内部的敌人。一直关注这类评论的两个人是亚历山大和瑞秋·温德曼。亚历克斯是正式报告看起来像唐纳德·特朗普总统和乌克兰总统之间不当通话的陆军军官，这导致了特朗普的第一次弹劾审判。瑞秋是他的妻子。
Back in March, I visited them. And they did not agree about what they were going to do if President Trump won another term and started taking revenge. Rachel said they should consider leaving the country if things got bad enough. Alex said he'd never consider that.
三月回国，我拜访了他们。他们不同意如果唐纳德·特朗普赢得了另一个任期并开始报复他们会做什么。瑞秋说如果情况变得足够糟糕，他们应该考虑离开这个国家。亚历克斯说他永远不会考虑这一点。
No, not possible. I think the fact is that I served a full military career to protect this country, and I'm not going to give it up.
不，不可能。我认为事实是我服役了完整的军事生涯以保护这个国家，我不会放弃它。
My argument is, if Donald Trump is reelected, this will no longer be that country. This will be the place where that country was. I want to be able to leave if I feel like that's what I need to, to protect mainly my daughter.
我的论点是，如果唐纳德·特朗普再次当选，这将不再是那个国家。这将是那个国家所在的地方。如果我觉得那是保护我女儿所需，我想要能够离开。
We were doing this interview in their living room. And we were standing, because they hadn't bought furniture for it yet. They wanted to wait and see what the outcome of the election was going to be first.
我们在他们的客厅里进行这次采访。而且我们站着，因为他们还没给它买家具。他们想等到选举结果出来先。
For Alex, this was just prudence and saving money against an uncertain future. For Rachel, it was, maybe we'll have to leave this house. When I reached out this week after the election, Alex didn't return my text to set up an interview, but Rachel was happy to talk. She told me they did finally bite the bullet and buy furniture in those early days when Kamala Harris took over as the Democratic nominee.
对亚历克斯来说，这只是谨慎和针对不确定未来的省钱。对瑞秋来说，是，也许我们将不得不离开这所房子。当我在选举后本周联系时，亚历克斯没有回复我的短信来安排采访，但瑞秋很高兴谈谈。她告诉我他们确实终于咬牙在卡马拉·哈里斯接手成为民主党提名人的那些早些日子买了家具。
We have two sofas, and we have a coffee table and a side piece thing. I don't know. But that's [INAUDIBLE]. We ordered it after all the buzz about her, and everyone was very excited. And we were just like, we're going to stay here. And I think we were very optimistic. So--
我们有两个沙发，我们有一个咖啡桌和一个侧面的东西。我不知道。但那是[听不清]。我们在关于她的所有炒作后订购了它，每个人都很兴奋。而且我们只是像，我们要留在这里。而且我认为我们非常乐观。所以——
In the months leading up to the election, Alex and Rachel have both been campaigning actively for Harris, speaking at fundraisers, that kind of thing. Rachel says she's probably done three events a week for the last six weeks, on video or in person, in all seven swing states.
在选举前的几个月里，亚历克斯和瑞秋都一直在积极为哈里斯竞选，在筹款活动中发言，那种事情。瑞秋说她过去六周大概每周做了三个活动，在视频或现场，在所有七个摇摆州。
We'd had plans to talk on election night once the winner was clear. But when I texted them, Rachel wrote back she didn't feel up to talking. "I am freaking out," she said. When we got on the phone later in the week, I asked if their views had changed since we talked in March. Was it still that she would consider leaving the country and he wouldn't?
我们本来计划在选举之夜一旦获胜者清楚就交谈。但当我给他们发短信时，瑞秋回信说她没心情谈。“我在崩溃，”她说。当我们稍后在周通过电话时，我问他们的观点是否从我们在三月交谈以来改变了。还是她会考虑离开这个国家而他不？
Nothing is off the table, but I want to stay, because this is my country. And I think there's a possibility to continue to be here and to be part of the discussion and make a difference. Alex absolutely wants to stay. It's not even a question. So maybe my decision is just based on his obstinance that it's a non-starter. So I have to bring myself around to that reality.
没有什么是不可能的，但我想要留下来，因为这是我的国家。而且我认为有一个可能性继续留在这里并成为讨论的一部分并产生影响。亚历克斯绝对想要留下来。这甚至不是一个问题。所以也许我的决定只是基于他的固执，这是一个非启动器。所以我必须把自己带到那个现实。
I thought of you guys in the last weeks of the campaign, when it seemed like Donald Trump was increasing his calls for retaliation and talking about going after the enemies within the country. What do the two of you think this is going to mean for you? Do you feel like you're going to be facing some sort of retaliation? Do you feel like it's just a complete open question? Where are you on this?
在竞选的最后几周我想到你们，当看起来唐纳德·特朗普正在增加他对报复的呼吁并谈论去追究国家内部的敌人。你们两个认为这对你们意味着什么？你们觉得你们将面临某种报复吗？你们觉得这只是一个完全开放的问题吗？你们在这里处于什么位置？
We have no idea. It will depend on signals from their actions. That's the only way we'll know, is to see what they're doing. But there is this guy who has a retaliation list. It's a long list. It's, like, 300, 350 people, something like that. And Alex's name is on it.
我们不知道。这将取决于他们行动的信号。那是我们知道的唯一方式，是看他们在做什么。但有这个家伙有一个报复名单。这是一个长名单。它，像，300，350人，那样的东西。而且亚历克斯的名字在上面。
This is a list that was circulating on social media, put together by a Trump supporter, the people that he thinks deserve revenge. He has no affiliation with Trump. There's no sign that anybody in Trump world listens to him. But seeing Alex's name there was alarming, a reminder of how visible Alex is as somebody who stood up to the president and how likely a target he is for the real people in power.
这是一个在社交媒体上流传的名单，由一个特朗普支持者汇总，他认为值得报复的人。他与特朗普没有任何关系。没有任何迹象表明特朗普世界里的任何人听他的。但看到亚历克斯的名字在那里是令人担忧的，一个关于亚历克斯作为站起来反对总统的人是多么可见的提醒，以及他作为有权力的真人的目标有多么可能。
So that's a concern. But are they going to retaliate against all of those people? Will it be all at once, like Kristallnacht, or will it be over time? And do we have time if that's the road they go down? I don't know. Or will they just do it on January 20?
所以那是一个担忧。但他们会对所有那些人报复吗？这将是一次全部，像水晶之夜，还是会随时间？而且如果那是他们走下的路，我们有时间吗？我不知道。还是他们会在1月20日做它？
Yeah.
是的。
But we'll definitely be watching the indicators-- and a list of criteria to say if this, then this. Some kind of places or inflection points, which is terrifying. But we certainly haven't gotten to that point. Like everyone, we're trying to process all of this.
但我们将肯定会关注指标——以及如果这个，那么这个的标准列表。某种地方或转折点，这是可怕的。但我们当然还没到那一点。像每个人一样，我们正在试图消化所有这些。
Can you name another one of the indicators that you're going to keep an eye on?
你能说出你们要关注的另一个指标吗？
Let's say ramp up talks about retaliation, then yes. But maybe it was election rhetoric and that's not something that's going to come up. There are so many unknowns with Trump. He says he's going to do a lot of things that he doesn't do.
让我们说加紧谈论报复，那么是的。但也许那是竞选修辞，那不是将会出现的东西。特朗普有那么多未知数。他说他要做很多他没做的事。
They're going to keep an eye on his appointments, especially who he appoints as Secretary of Defense. Rachel pictures that retaliation against Alex could be as small as they try to take his retirement benefits, his health care, pension, or as big as they could put him on trial for his actions in the impeachment hearings. She really doesn't know what to expect.
他们将关注他的任命，特别是他任命谁作为国防部长。瑞秋设想针对亚历克斯的报复可能小到他们试图拿走他的退休福利、他的医疗保健、养老金，或大到他们可以因为他在弹劾听证会中的行动而对他进行审判。她真的不知道该期待什么。
What's your feeling? What's your gut?
你的感觉是什么？你的直觉是什么？
My head says it'll probably be OK. My heart is very scared. But I don't want to live my life in fear. I don't want to live in my own country afraid when neither I nor my husband has done anything wrong.
我的头脑说它可能没问题。我的心非常害怕。但我不想在恐惧中生活。我不想在自己的国家感到害怕，当我既没有也没有我的丈夫做任何错事时。
Rachel Vindman.
瑞秋·温德曼。
We reached out to the other people we interviewed in March for the episode we did about possible retribution Donald Trump might take to see how concerned they are about what might happen to them now. Former Trump aide Stephanie Grisham didn't return our calls. Fred Wellman, who used to be at the Lincoln Project, said he was watching to see how things were going to unfold. And he's gaming out possible scenarios for what he might do.
我们联系了我们在三月采访的其他人为我们制作的关于唐纳德·特朗普可能采取的可能报复的情节，看看他们有多关注现在可能发生在他们身上的事情。前特朗普助手斯蒂芬妮·格里沙姆没有回复我们的电话。曾经在林肯项目的弗雷德·韦尔曼说他正在观看事情将如何展开。而且他正在针对他可能做的事情制定可能的场景。
Act Four, "I've Done an Unbelievable Job on the Abortion Question." So I think, as everybody knows at this point, Kamala Harris and the Democrats were betting that abortion rights would help put her over the top. And 10 different states had abortion rights measures on their ballots. Seven of those passed. And there was a very particular kind of TV ad that aired in many of those states, all with a very particular feeling and particular music, very similar language.
第四幕，“我在堕胎问题上做了一项难以置信的工作”。所以我认为，正如每个人在这一点上都知道的，卡马拉·哈里斯和民主党人是在打赌堕胎权会帮助她越过顶端。而10个不同的州在他们的选票上有堕胎权措施。七个通过了。而且有一种非常特定的电视广告在许多那些州播出，都有一个非常特定的感觉和特定的音乐，非常相似的语言。
In these ads, women whose lives have been put at risk from complications with their pregnancies told their stories to explain why abortion bans needed to be lifted. One of our producers, Miki Meek, became interested in these commercials. And this week, she checked in with a few of the people who appeared in them. Here's Miki.
在这些广告中，生活因怀孕并发症而处于危险中的妇女讲述她们的故事来解释为什么堕胎禁令需要被解除。我们的制作人之一，米基·米克，对这些商业广告产生了兴趣。而本周，她核实了几个出现在其中的人。这是米基。
Since Roe was struck down two years ago, I've been reporting on pregnant women and doctors in states with abortion bans. And I've noticed that it's almost always the same group of women, about 20 in all, being called on again and again to recount the worst moments of their lives in media interviews, in court cases, at their state legislatures, and in Congress.
自从罗诉韦德案两年前被推翻以来，我一直在报道各州的孕妇和医生有堕胎禁令。而且我注意到几乎总是同一组妇女，约20人，被一次又一次地叫出来在媒体采访、法庭案件、在他们的州立法机构和国会中叙述她们生活中最糟糕的时刻。
I don't love it, to be perfectly honest. I feel like it's really--
我不喜欢它，要完全诚实。我觉得它真的很——
That's Kimberly Paseka, who was denied an abortion in Nebraska. She shared her story in one of those ads.
那是金伯利·帕塞卡，她在内布拉斯加州被拒绝堕胎。她在那些广告之一中分享了她的故事。
It's disheartening that we are putting the toughest conversation on the people who are affected the most-- and having to relive that trauma and just relive the worst parts of their life to try and make change. And even today, I'm sitting here, and I'm exhausted. It's like, how am I even standing here still? The last two-plus months has just been exhausting. And you see online and people are like, we have to keep fighting. And I'm like, I have been fighting. Where have you been?
令人沮丧的是，我们把最艰难的对话放在最受影响的人身上——并且必须重温那种创伤，只是重温她们生活中最糟糕的部分来试图做出改变。即使今天，我坐在这里，而且我很疲惫。它像，我甚至还站在那里？过去两加月只是令人疲惫。而且你在网上看到，人们像，我们必须继续战斗。而且我像，我一直在战斗。你在哪里？
Nebraska's abortion rights measure failed this week.
内布拉斯加州的堕胎权措施本周失败了。
I actually-- I made the joke to my husband yesterday. I was like, all my new followers on Twitter are going to be so disappointed when I start just posting about basketball and football again.
我实际上——我昨天给我的丈夫开了个玩笑。我像，我在推特上的所有新粉丝都会如此失望，当我开始再次只是发布关于篮球和足球时。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Until we resolve the issue, I feel like I'll always say something. But I am going to have to step away from it for a little bit, just for my sanity, I think. I don't think I'll ever stop pushing how important the issue is, though, because until there aren't any bans, some woman's always going to be affected. Some girl's going to be affected. And I hate that for this country.
直到我们解决这个问题，我觉得我总会说些什么。但我将不得不从它稍微退后一点，只是为了我的理智，我想。我不认为我会停止推动问题的重要性，虽然，因为直到没有任何禁令，一些妇女总是会受到影响。一些女孩会受到影响。而且我恨这个国家。
Of all the ads I watched, Deborah Dorbert's really got to me. It was so emotional I almost couldn't finish it. Debra's 34 years old and from Florida. She's got a six-year-old son. Two years ago, she was 23 weeks pregnant with her second child when she went into her doctor's office for a routine scan and learned that her baby had a lethal and rare condition called Potter Syndrome. He had no kidneys. His lungs weren't developing. If he survived birth, he wouldn't live long, maybe just minutes.
在我看过的所有广告中，黛博拉·多伯特的真正得到了我。它太情绪化了，我几乎不能完成它。黛博拉34岁，来自佛罗里达。她有一个六岁的儿子。两年前，她怀着第二个孩子23周时，她去她的医生办公室进行常规扫描并了解到她的婴儿有一种致命且罕见的病症叫波特综合征。他没有肾脏。他的肺部没有发育。如果他出生存活，他不会活很长时间，也许只是几分钟。
Her doctor recommended she terminate the pregnancy as soon as possible. She was now at higher risk for preeclampsia, which could kill her. Deborah agreed. She also didn't want her baby to suffer. But Florida had just banned all abortions after 15 weeks, with some rare and vague exceptions. Deborah says the hospital told her that because her baby still had a heartbeat, they couldn't help her.
她的医生建议她尽快终止妊娠。她现在处于先兆子痫的高风险中，这可能会杀死她。黛博拉同意了。她也不想她的婴儿受苦。但佛罗里达州刚刚禁止了15周后的所有堕胎，有一些罕见和模糊的例外。黛博拉说医院告诉她，因为她的婴儿仍然有心跳，他们不能帮她。
They were actually wrong about this. Florida's law allows for abortions in cases where there's a lethal fetal anomaly up to 28 weeks. But there's a lot of fear and confusion among doctors and hospitals in states with bans. So Deborah had to carry the baby to term, knowing all along he wouldn't survive. She and her husband named him Milo. He lived for 94 minutes.
他们实际上对此错了。佛罗里达州的法律允许在有致命胎儿异常的情况下进行堕胎，直到28周。但有大量的恐惧和混乱在有禁令的州的医生和医院之间。所以黛博拉不得不把孩子带到足月，一直知道他不会存活。她和她的丈夫给他取名叫米洛。他活了94分钟。
Deborah's husband told me he didn't expect her to speak publicly, seemed out of character. And it felt that way to her too. Deborah describes herself as shy, reserved, conflict-averse. But while she was still pregnant with Milo, she was so angry and depressed that she decided to talk to a reporter from the Washington Post. And after she gave birth, she decided to keep talking.
黛博拉的丈夫告诉我，他没期望她公开说话，对她来说似乎不符合性格。而且那对她来说也是那种感觉。黛博拉形容自己害羞、矜持、回避冲突。但在她仍然怀着米洛时，她太生气和沮丧，以至于她决定和一个来自华盛顿邮报的记者谈谈。而且在她生下孩子后，她决定继续谈话。
Is there a specific conversation or interaction you had with someone where you realized, I did change their opinion about Florida's abortion law?
有没有一个特定的对话或互动你和一个意识到的人，我确实改变了他们关于佛罗里达堕胎法的意见？
My parents. My parents, they are very conservative people. And it was my dad, having witnessed what I went through when-- he found out the news, and then he found out that I could not get induced and I was being forced to carry to full term. And he had to watch his daughter suffer for months, and he didn't understand why I could not get the care I needed.
我的父母。我的父母，他们是非常保守的人。而且那是我的父亲，目睹了我就算经历了什么——他发现了新闻，然后他发现我不能被引产，而且我被迫怀到足月。而且他不得不看着他的女儿受苦数月，而且他不理解为什么我不能得到我需要的照顾。
Her parents are Catholic, and before this, they were against abortion. But seeing her experience up close changed them. So when the organizers of the ballot measure in Florida approached her to do a TV ad, she said yes. The measure would put abortion rights into the state constitution.
她的父母是天主教徒，而且在此之前，他们反对堕胎。但近距离看到她的经历改变了他们。所以当佛罗里达州投票措施的组织者接近她做电视广告时，她说好。该措施将把堕胎权放入州宪法。
I remember the doctor handing me a baby boy that was blue, and I just held him because he was so cold.
我记得医生递给我一个蓝色的男婴，我只是抱着他，因为他太冷了。
In the ad, Deborah is sitting on a couch in a green dress. Her husband, Lee, is right next to her, his arm wrapped around her.
在广告中，黛博拉坐在绿色连衣裙的沙发上。她的丈夫，李，就在她旁边，他的手臂裹着她。
Government had no right to do that to my family. This ban is torture.
政府没权利对我的家庭那样做。这个禁令是酷刑。
Governor DeSantis fought the abortion measure hard. He sent plainclothes police to knock on doors looking for fraudulent signatures on the petition for the ballot measure. The Florida Health Department sent cease and desist letters to TV stations, airing a different ad that supported the measure. A judge siding with the TV stations wrote, "To keep it simple for the state of Florida, it's the First Amendment, stupid."
德桑蒂斯州长强硬地打击了堕胎措施。他派遣便衣警察去敲门寻找请愿书上欺诈性的签名。佛罗里达卫生部向电视站发送了停止和中止信，播出了一个支持该措施的不同广告。一个站在电视站一边的法官写道，“为了让它对佛罗里达州保持简单，这是第一修正案，愚蠢。”
On election night. Deborah and her husband headed to a watch party with organizers of the ballot measure, a group called Yes on 4. There were balloons everywhere, a full bar. Deborah felt hopeful and had a speech prepared if the measure got passed. Ever since Roe was overturned, whenever voters got a chance to vote on abortion measures like this one, they passed, even in red states.
在选举之夜。黛博拉和她的丈夫前往一个观看派对，派对由投票措施的组织者举行，一个叫“4号是”的团体。到处都是气球，一个完整的酒吧。黛博拉感觉充满希望，如果措施获得通过，她准备了一个演讲。自从罗被推翻以来，每当选民有机会对像这样的堕胎措施进行投票时，它们就通过了，即使在红色州。
Around 9:00 PM, the results were in. A clear majority of Floridians voted in favor of the ballot initiative, but it still failed because in Florida, ballot measures need 60% of the vote to pass. It got 57%.
晚上9:00左右，结果出来了。清楚多数佛罗里达人投票赞成投票倡议，但它仍然失败了，因为在佛罗里达，投票措施需要60%的票数才能通过。它获得了57%。
We were upstairs in a private little room, just waiting for the results. And once they told me that Yes on 4 failed, it was just-- honestly, it was a shock. It was like a punch in the stomach, and it just brought me back to that day in the doctor's office. And it was just that shock and that numb.
我们在楼上一个小房间里，只是等待结果。而且一旦他们告诉我4号是失败了，它只是——老实说，这是一个震惊。它像胃部的重击，而且它只是把我带回了医生办公室的那一天。而且那只是那个震惊和那个麻木。
We did go downstairs to hear the director speak. And after she spoke and a few other guests spoke, I remember getting up out of the room and going outside. And that is when I just broke down crying. And my husband came and found me. And I was on my knees and crying because it just-- the law took everything from me.
我们确实下楼去听导演说话。而且在她说话以及其他几个客人说话后，我记得我走出房间，走到外面。而且那时我只是崩溃大哭。而且我的丈夫来找到了我。而且我跪在地上哭，因为它只是——法律从我这里拿走了所有东西。
It's one thing to decide to tell this painful story over and over, but it's another thing to do it and not get the results you wanted.
决定一次又一次地讲述这个痛苦的故事是一回事，但做它却得不到你想要的结果是另一回事。
It's hard. You feel like a lot of weight is on your shoulders to try to get the government and legislation to understand, like, look what these laws are doing. I do feel tired. Just sharing my story is a lot of work.
它很难。你觉得很多重量都在你的肩上，试图让政府和立法机构理解，像，看看这些法律在做什么。我确实感到疲惫。分享我的故事是很多工作。
Do you ever have the feeling of, when can I be done and stop talking about this?
你是否有过，什么时候我可以完成并停止谈论这个的感觉？
So yesterday, we spent a lot of time navigating, do we keep fighting this fight or do we just step away? And for me, I'm up on the fence. I don't want to back down now. I want to see through that the law gets changed.
所以昨天，我们花了很多时间导航，我们继续战斗这场战斗吗还是我们只是退后？而且对我来说，我在栅栏上。我现在不想退缩。我想看到法律被改变。
What people don't see when Deborah tells her story in public is how hard she's still trying to get back to real life, just enjoy small moments again-- karate classes on Thursdays, pizza night on Fridays with her husband and her six-year-old son.
当黛博拉公开讲述她的故事时，人们看不到的是她仍然多么努力地试图回到现实生活，只是再次享受小小的时刻——星期四的空手道课，星期五的披萨之夜与她的丈夫和她六岁的儿子。
Miki Meek is a producer on our show.
米基·米克是我们节目的制作人。
["MORNING IN AMERICA" BY DURAND JONES & THE INDICATIONS]
["美国清晨" 由杜兰德·琼斯 & 指示]
Well, our show today was produced and edited by Laura Starcheski and Emanuele Berry. The people who put together today's program include Bim Adewunmi, Phia Bennin, Dana Chivvis, Sean Cole, Michael Comite, Emmanuel Dzotsi, Hany Hawasly, Valerie Kipnis, Henry Larson, Seth Lind, Katherine Rae Mondo, Stowe Nelson. Ryan Rumery, Alissa Shipp, Alix Spiegel, Lilly Sullivan, Christopher Swetala, Marisa Robertson-Textor, Matt Tierney, and Diane Wu. Our managing editor's Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editor's David Kestenbaum.
嗯，我们今天的节目是由劳拉·斯塔切斯基和伊曼纽尔·贝里制作和编辑的。把今天的程序放在一起的人包括比姆·阿德武米、菲亚·本宁、达纳·奇维斯、肖恩·科尔、迈克尔·科米特、伊曼纽尔·佐齐、哈尼·哈瓦斯利、瓦莱丽·基普尼斯、亨利·拉尔森、塞思·林德、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、斯托·尼尔森。瑞安·鲁梅里、艾丽莎·希普、阿利克斯·斯皮格尔、莉莉·沙利文、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉、玛丽莎·罗伯逊-泰克斯特、马特·蒂尔尼和黛安·吴。我们的主编是莎拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼。我们的高级编辑是大卫·克斯滕鲍姆。
Special thanks today to Andrea Flores, Aaron Reichlin-Melnick, Jonathan Blitzer, Miriam Rosenbaum, Colin Jackson, Jon Smith, Patrice Johnson, Fields Moseley, Jen Fifield, Ben Giles, Yvonne Wingette-Sanchez, Ben Terris, Neil Makhija, Rebecca Tyrrell, Drew Reisinger, Kathie Kline, Paul Choi, Jordan Green, Lee Dorbert, Adama Bah, and Candice Braun and Power Malu of Artists Athletes Activists in New York City.
今天的特别感谢安德里亚·弗洛雷斯、亚伦·赖希林-梅尔尼克、乔纳森·布利策、米里亚姆·罗森鲍姆、科林·杰克逊、乔恩·史密斯、帕特里斯·约翰逊、菲尔兹·莫斯利、詹·菲菲尔德、本·贾尔斯、伊冯·温格特-桑切斯、本·特里斯、尼尔·马希贾、丽贝卡·泰瑞尔、德鲁·赖辛格、凯西·克莱恩、保罗·崔、乔丹·格林、李·多伯特、阿达马·巴、以及纽约市艺术家运动员活动家组织的坎迪斯·布劳恩和权力马卢。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. To become a This American Life Partner and get bonus content, ad-free listening, ask me anything sessions, and a greatest-hits archive of hundreds of favorite episodes right in your podcast feed, sign up at thisamericanlife.org/lifepartners. Thanks this week to Life Partners Kira Elert, Rachael MacFarlane, Martha Stroud, and Lauren Talerman.
《美国生活》由PRX，公共广播交易所交付给公共广播电台。要成为一名美国生活合作伙伴并获得额外内容、无广告收听、问我任何会议，以及播客提要中数百个最喜爱剧集的精华存档，请在 thisamericanlife.org/lifepartners 注册。感谢本周的生活合作伙伴基拉·埃勒特、瑞秋·麦克法兰、玛莎·斯特劳德和劳伦·塔勒曼。
Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, he is such an annoying person to meditate with, seriously. Every time we're finally into it and have quieted our minds, he starts chanting super loudly--
感谢，一如既往，我们节目的共同创始人，托里·马拉蒂亚先生。你知道，他是 meditation 与一个如此讨厌的人，严肃地说。每次我们最终进入它并安静了我们的头脑，他开始大声吟唱——
This is the deep state. This is the deep state.
这是深层政府。这是深层政府。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多美国生活的故事回来。
["MORNING IN AMERICA" BY DURAND JONES & THE INDICATIONS]
["美国清晨" 由杜兰德·琼斯 & 指示]